[Music]
[Music]
welcome all to the ninth lecture serious
in our fault serious God and computers
minds machines and metaphysics I welcome
you all and specifically the students
who are at the end of the term and have
certainly a lot of other things to do
welcome here for all people who want to
discuss a little bit beyond the question
sessions we have to died and usually
after the question serious on Monday
December 7th at Harvard Divinity School
at 12 o'clock Harvey Cox and me run
again in discussion group on this
lecture serious 12 o'clock Harvard
Divinity School on Monday so for all
people who want to talk about issues
which go a little bit beyond what we can
answer in this lecture series so far we
had two two different paragraphs in this
lecture series the first four lectures
in the serious dealt with what does it
mean to be human what is the so-called
human factor the second lecture that the
second part of the lecture series then
the next four lectures presented case
studies from a Catholic a Jewish a Hindu
and a Buddhist perspective on how
scientists deal with existential issues
within and outside of their research and
the last two lectures we have today and
next Wednesday our lectures dealing now
going back to computer science and deal
with questions on computer science
computers and God and so I'm
particularly happy to welcome today ray
courts well Ray Kurzweil is actually
founder of no less than four companies
one is correspond technologies in
cooperation which is a consulting firm
patent firms and other other consulting
issues the other one is quartz while
education system Ray Kurzweil has
invented a couple of very innovative
technologies here in that company he
distributes reading software for blind
people it is quartz well applied
intelligence in corporation where he has
invented voice-command software and
finally its course
music system where he has invented a lot
of professional musician systems for
computers and so I was actually
impressed already by that list of
companies but what was even more
impressed because his innovative
technology is not the only part of why
he is so much accepted but he's also
very much accepted within academia
because his in contributions to computer
science and academia are enormous and so
he got no less than nine honorary
Doctorate degrees in science and
engineering and in music received
numerous awards and I was also only
mentioned to one is the inventor of the
year at MIT and the other one is that he
received the award for the most
outstanding computer science book of
1990 for his book the age of intelligent
machines which was published in 1990 by
MIT press I can highly recommend that
book it's very fun to read and he's
currently working on another book which
is called the age of spiritual machines
and I'm very very happy that you are
here today to share with us the thoughts
about this book welcome
my wife is annoyed that I skipped the
age of emotional machines but we'll try
to cover that as well it's a pleasure to
be here at my old stomping grounds when
I was a student here we had one IBM 7090
4 which was shared by several thousand
students and professors you needed some
influence to get more than a few seconds
a day and it ran at a quarter of a mil
and had 32k of of ram actually core core
memory was it was back then
so things have progressed a bit actually
in lockstep to Moore's law which which
we'll talk a little bit about let me
start with a story that some of you may
recognize but I think for a lot of you
might be before your time
The Gambler had not expected to be here
but on reflection he thought yes he had
shown some kindness in his time and this
place was even more beautiful and
satisfying than he had imagined
everywhere there were magnificent
crystal chandeliers the finest handmade
carpets the most sumptuous foods and yes
the most beautiful women who seemed
intrigued with their new heaven made he
tried his hand at roulette and amazingly
his number came up time after time he
tried the gaming tables and his luck was
nothing short of remarkable winning game
after game indeed his winnings were
causing quite a stir attracting much
excitement by the attentive staff and by
the beautiful women
this continued day after day week after
week with the gambler winning every game
accumulating bigger and bigger winnings
everything was going his way he just
kept on winning and winning and week
after week and month after month the
gamblers winning streak seemed
unbreakable after a while this started
to get tedious the gambler was getting
agitated the winning was starting to
lose its meaning but nothing changed he
just kept on winning every game until
one day the now anguished gambler turned
to the angel who seemed to be in charge
and said that he couldn't take it in
more heaven was not for him after all he
had really figured he was destined for
the other place after all and indeed
that's where he wanted to be but this is
the other place came the replying that's
that's my recollection of a episode of
The Twilight Zone that I saw as a young
child anybody here happen to see that
episode I think the title might have
been something like be careful what you
wish for or at least that's what I would
call it and as this engaging seriously
want to do it Illustrated many of the
paradoxes of human nature we like to
solve problems but we don't want them
all solved not too quickly anyway we're
more attached to the problems than the
solutions maybe to the process of
solving them take death for example a
great deal of our effort goes into
avoiding it we make extraordinary
efforts to delay it and indeed often
consider its intrusion as a tragic event
yet we would find it hard to live
without it death gives meaning to our
lives
it gives importance and value to time
time would become meaningless if there
were too much of it if death were
indefinitely put off or even just put
off for a very long time in human terms
the human psyche would end up well like
the gambler and the twilight zone
now we don't yet have this predicament
we have no shortage today of either
death or human problems few observers
feel that the 20th century has left us
with too much of a good thing there is
growing prosperity fueled not
incidentally by information technology
but the human species is still
challenged with issues and difficulties
not altogether different than those that
has struggled with from the beginning of
our recorded history the 21st century
will be different in my view the human
species along with the computational
technology that in it initiated the
creation of will solve age-old problems
of need if not desire and will be in a
position to change the nature of
mortality in a post biological future
I'll explain what I mean about that
a little bit later now do we have the
psychological capacity too for all the
good things that await us
probably not but that might change as
well before the next century is over
human beings will no longer be the most
intelligent or capable type of entity on
the planet
now as the abstract pointed out let me
take that controversial statement back
the truth of that statement depends on
how we define human and that will be a
key issue in the next century
unlike the 20th century the primary
political and philosophical issue will
be the definition of who we are but I'm
getting a little bit of ahead of myself
to approach the 21st century we need to
start from the present if we jump to the
endgame it's a little unsettling and
maybe not quite believable but if we
take it step by step I think we'll see
the inexorable logic of the next century
this last century has seen enormous
technological change and the social
upheavals that go along with it which
few pundits circa 1899 foresaw and the
pace of change is accelerating and it
has been since the inception of
invention and as we will discuss this
acceleration is an inherent feature of
technology that's what makes technology
different from just simply the use of
tools or a lot of animals that use tools
or at least there are some but those
tools don't evolve with time our tools
evolve the genes of that evolution are
really our own knowledge base which we
use to advance technology and that's an
inherent nature of technology the result
will be far greater transformations in
the first two decades of the 21st
century than we saw in the entire 20th
century but there Priestley appreciate
the logic of this we have to go back and
start with the present now computers
today exceed human intelligence in a
broad variety of intelligence yet very
narrow domains such as playing chess
diagnosing certain medical conditions
timing buy and sell decisions grot
guiding cruise missiles and so on yet
human intelligence remains far more
supple and flexible
computers are still unable to tell the
difference between a dog and a cat
although I actually I've been saying
that for years I think we probably could
program some neural nets a data to make
that distinction but computers can't tie
a pair of shoelaces I can't describe the
objects on a crowded kitchen table write
a summary of a movie recognize humor or
provide other subtle tasks in which
their human creators excel now one
reason for this disparity in
capabilities is that our most advanced
computers still remain far simpler
devices than the human brain by a factor
of approximately a million give or take
a couple of orders of magnitude
depending on what assumptions you use
but computers as is well known have been
doubling in speed and capacity or
complexity which it's important to point
out is actually a quadrupling of
computational ability every 18 months
since the inception of calculating
devices at the beginning of the century
and this trend will continue I'll come
back to Moore's law in a moment but if
we extrapolate that out computers will
achieve the computing speed and capacity
of the human brain by around the year
2020
now of course achieving the basic
complexity and capacity of the human
brain will not automatically result in
computers matching the flexibility and
range of human intelligence the
organization and content of these
resources that is the software of
intelligence is equally important and in
a few minutes I'll talk about at least
one scenario that I think is credible to
achieve this now once a computer it
achieves a human level of intelligence
it will necessarily roar past it since
their inception computers have been far
more powerful than computers in memory
and speed the computer can remember
billions or trillions of facts with
extreme reliability can extract
information from billions of items in a
database in a matter of seconds we're
hard-pressed to remember handful of
phone numbers or the directions to get
here
the combination of human level
intelligence in a machine with the fact
that electronic circuits are a million
times faster than neural circuits
combined with the computers inherent
superiority in speed and reliability of
memory will be a very formidable
combination now as I mentioned
electronic circuits are a million times
faster than neural circuits so once a
computer achieves a human level of
ability in understanding abstract
concepts recognizing patterns the
ability to read for example it'll be
able to apply this ability to a
knowledge base of all human acquired
knowledge in fact there's a project in
Kyoto at ATR Advanced Technology
Research Laboratory where they're
building a billion neuron neural net and
they plan to teach it the ability to
read and then we'll basically set it
loose on all published human literature
at least that that's available
electronic form now a common reaction to
the proposition that computers will
seriously compete with human
intelligence is to dismiss the specter
based primarily on an examination of
contemporary capability I mean after all
when you interact with your personal
computer its intelligence seems limited
and brittle if it seems intelligent at
all it's hard to imagine one's personal
computer having a sense of humor holding
an opinion or displaying any of the
other endearing qualities of human
intelligence but the state-of-the-art in
computer technology is anything but
static computer capabilities are
emerging today they were considered
impossible one or two decades ago
examples include the ability to
accurately transcribe normal continuous
speech which all three leading companies
in speech recognition dragon my own
company Creswell pod intelligence in IBM
recently demonstrated at Comdex the
ability to intelligently respond to
natural language to recognize patterns
and medical tests such as electric
cartograms and blood cell tests with an
accuracy exceeding human physicians and
of course to play chess at a world
championship level in the next decade
we'll see translating telephones but my
company because we're all intelligence
was recently acquired by learn how to
house be that has language translation
software and we're putting together a
translating telephone with continuous
speech recognition text to text language
translation and text to speech so
this is and we plan to hold a
demonstration early in 1998 where you'll
be able to call up somebody in Germany
and hold a conversation in real time
with your speech translate into German
and vice-versa in the second decade of
the next century it'll become
increasingly difficult to draw any clear
distinction between the capabilities of
human and machine intelligence evolution
has been seen as a billion-year drama
that led inexorably to its grandest
creation human intelligence the
emergence in the early 21st century of a
new form of intelligence that can
compete with and in some marine is at
least exceed that of human intelligence
will be in my view a development of
Greater import than anything we saw in
the 20th century now this Spectre is not
yet here
computers today are still a great deal
simpler than the human brain but with
the emergence of computers that really
rival and exceed the human brain and
complexity will be will come a
corresponding ability of machines to
understand and respond to abstractions
and to subtleties human beings appear to
be complex in part because of their
competing internal goals things we call
values emotions represent and engender
sub-goals that often conflict and in my
view are an unavoidable byproduct of the
complexity that is human nature as
computers achieve a comparable level of
complexity and as they are increasingly
derived from models of human
intelligence they too will necessarily
utilize goals that appear to exhibit
values and emotions of course not always
the same values and emotions that humans
exhibit and a variety of philosophical
issues will emerge our computers
thinking or are they just calculating
conversely our human beings thinking or
are we just calculating presumably our
brains follow the laws of physics so
they must be machines I'll be at very
complex ones
is there inherent difference between
machine thinking and human thinking to
put it another way once computers are as
complex as the human brain and can match
the human brain in the subtlety and
complexity of thought are we to consider
them conscious
it's a difficult issue to even pose some
philosophers feel it's not a meaningful
question other philosophers feel it's
the only meaningful question in
philosophy and the question actually
goes back to Plato's time they had
debates on this issue and imagined
machines of the complexity of the human
brain made up of pistons and wires and
levers and so on but as we actually have
machines that genuinely appear to
possess volition and emotional responses
this issue will become increasingly
compelling now let's talk for a moment
about what it will take to achieve just
the hardware capacity of the human brain
as is well known computers have been
doubling in speed and also the density
of computation which if you have a
massively parallel neural net actually
means you can put twice as many neurons
rather than twice as fast which is
really a quadrupling of the number of
neural connection calculations you can
do per second every 18 months computer
memory today is about a billion times
more powerful for the same unit cost and
it was when I was born and if the only
real industry had made as much progress
in the last half-century cause today
would cost a hundredth of a cent and go
faster than the speed of light now this
this exponential progress is called
Moore's Law how many people here
familiar with Moore's law I expect a lot
of hands to go up here Intel chairman
Gordon Moore first commented on this
actually in the comment they didn't in
the mid 70s he said it was 24 months in
the mid 80s he revised that to 18 months
it's a corollary of a broader law since
nobody's claimed that I've named it
Kurzweil was law on the exponentially
quickening pace of technology that goes
back to the dawn of recorded history I
mean not much happened in say the 10th
century technologically speaking there
may have been one or two things in the
18th century quite a bit happened the
19th century a lot happened and now in
the 20th century we have major paradigm
shifts in a few years time now some
observers have commented that
exponential trends can't go on
forever and we have plenty lots of
examples of exponential trends that go
along and then just hit a wall like a
species happening upon a new habitat is
the classical example it's numbers will
will multiply geometrically for time and
then hits a wall I may even go in
Reverse when it exhausts the the supply
in its new habitat but it would be
highly premature to predict the end of
Moore's Law anytime soon the chip
companies themselves have said they can
confidently four-seat twenty more years
of Moore's law just using conventional
approaches that that alone is enough to
put the computational capacity of the
human brain into $1,000 personal
computer moreover today's chips are
essentially flat with only one layer of
circuitry whereas the brain uses all
three dimensions we live in a
three-dimensional world why not use all
three dimensions and circuits
particularly superconducting circuits
that don't generate heat will enable the
development of chips or should say cubes
with thousands of layers of circuitry
and also smaller component geometries
which will multiply computing capacity
by a factor of millions there are more
than enough computing technologies to
assure the continuation of Moore's law
for a very long time
now the human brain has about a hundred
billion neurons on average they have
about a thousand connections from one
neuron to the next that's a hundred
trillion connections each connections
capable of a computation so that's a
hundred trillion fold parallelism these
circuits are very slow I mean if we just
copied the human brain in electronic
form it would run a million times faster
because the neural circuits run 200
calculations per second typical
electronic circuits 200 million
calculations a second but 200 times 100
trillion is 20 million billion
calculations per second and that's about
what you get in the year 2020 in a
thousand-dollar personal computer if you
if you just track Moore's law and again
the chip companies feel that they can do
that just with conventional approaches
not even computing not even assuming
things like Cristal and computers and
DNA computers now
computers and quantum computers which is
itself an interesting subject because
it's a whole different type of
computation but I won't get sidetracked
on that but or and by the way if we were
to harvest even a fraction of the unused
computes on the internet and there are
some proposals for doing that we could
create virtual supercomputers with the
computing capacity of the human brain
today now as we achieve each new level
of hardware capacity new software
technologies become feasible and in fact
it becomes a compelling economic
pressure to create software that matches
the hardware capability and one of the
exciting things about Moore's Law is
every time that that screw turns whole
new business opportunities become
available as I mentioned continuous
speech with natural language
understanding is now feasible a product
that Kurzweil intelligence showed at
Comdex recently which got one of the
four best of Comdex citations allows you
to say things like I enjoyed my trip to
Belgium last week make this paragraph
two points bigger and change its font to
Arial I hope to go back to Belgium soon
and it actually figures out that that
second sentence is a command and then
carries it out and you can say the
commands in any way that you want these
systems require two hundred megahertz
Pentiums with 32 megabytes the point is
that as hardware capacity becomes
available software capacities do follow
and we will see the same phenomena with
the full range of init of human
intellect which of course is comprised
of many different types of skills now
there are a number of convincing
scenarios we could discuss but let me
concentrate on just one which I find
particularly compelling which is reverse
engineering the human brain I mean the
design is right there in front of us and
it's not at all impossible to get at the
information as the hardware capacity to
emulate the human brain 20 million
billion calculations per second and
that's conservatively high I've seen
other estimates that are a thousand
times lower but as a capacity becomes
available we're not there yet but we
will be
in a couple of decades projects to scan
and understand the algorithms of the
brain will be initiated in fact that's
already been started Carver Mead his
company synaptics basically studied
mammalian early vision neural the neural
organization of mammalian early vision
by looking at cat Cortex's and by
examining the topology of the
interneuronal connections the algorithms
are become apparent and it's not hard to
see them now these are not conventional
sequential von Neumann algorithms these
are not all digital algorithms these are
hybrid digital analog algorithms they're
massively parallel they're not also
conventional neural net algorithms
they're specialized neural net
algorithms but you can see them by
examining the topology of the neural
connections and they created a chip that
in fact duplicates mammalian early
vision now it's feasible today to
perform a destructive scan of the human
brain you could freeze a brain and
destructively scan it and see all of the
connections of some once it's recently
deceased saying now we might not want to
base our templates of intelligence on
someone who's recently deceased better
to catch someone before they died
recently a serial killer agreed to be
scanned before he was executed and you
can buy all 500 megabytes of him on the
cd-rom this is this is available we may
not want to base our designs on it on
the mind of a serial killer either but
in terms of non-invasive scanning
magnetic resonance imaging today can
image individual sohmas or nerve cell
bodies we can see individual cells with
today's MRI and the limitation of the
resolution and speed of MRI is the speed
of computation so as computers get
faster MRI is a very computationally
intensive process our MRIs can be higher
resolution and in about 10 years and
the design of of MRIs now being designed
which will be in the market in four or
five years can can see individual see
the individual connections the axons
dendrites synapses and other neural
components that make up the internal
wiring it will be feasible to actually
reverse engineer these connections with
MRI in about 10 years eventually we will
be able to resolve the pre synaptic
vesicles that many scientists believe is
the site of human learning just as the
human genome project is providing us
with the templates of the human genetic
system efforts to scan the neural
organization of the brain will provide
us with the templates of intelligence
and I will point out that there was a
lot of skepticism about the genome
project 20 years ago and I mentioned
this project in in ATR in Kyoto where
they are in fact now building expect to
have this in a couple of years a billion
neuron neural net implemented in
Hardware not one of these software
neural nets and that's actually pretty
competitive with the human brain right
there now let's talk a little bit about
the impact of the emergence of a
thinking and feeling machine in this
book the edge of telogen machines which
I wrote ten years ago are predicted that
a computer would be world chess
championship champion before the turn of
the century and I went out to say that
when this happened we would either think
more of computers less of human
intelligence or less of chess and if
history was a guide we would think less
of chess and indeed that's exactly what
we're seeing every derivatives from Doug
Hofstadter to People magazine the
Scientific American have discovered that
chess is not so intelligent and creative
and endeavor after all rather it's
really a matter of brute force
computation for which computers are well
suited but continuing to defend the
superiority of human intellect in this
way as we go through the next couple of
decades
will become increasingly difficult a
competition from intelligent machines
may seem threatening so one might expect
constraints of one kind of an
to be placed on this phenomenon while
the human species is still in charge but
while the overall phenomena may appear
to be unsettling defining and
implementing any specific limitations
will not be at all straightforward and I
don't think will be feasible this
arrival on earth of intelligent entities
that rival human thinking is not an
alien invasion thinking machines are
humankind's own creation an evolution of
tools intended for our own product
productivity and efficiency and indeed
were already enormous ly dependent on
our intelligent machines just the
contemporary genre if all our computers
with the ceased operating society could
hardly function the drive to add
intelligence and knowledge to our
computing devices is fueled by a
compelling economic incentive we've
entered an age of knowledge in which the
knowledge content of products and
services is asymptoting to a hundred
percent of their value the enormous
market capitalization of the computer
industry one recent estimate put the
market cap of just Silicon Valley
companies started in the last ten years
at approximately a trillion dollars and
that's really where most of the wealth
today is being created there was another
large figure from MIT but it was
actually lower than Stanford's number
I'm not sure whether it is a might be
the warm weather there but a
computerized system that possesses more
flexible intelligence and greater
content renders its competition obsolete
stopping this process would require
repealing this basic engine of economic
competition now it may appear that we
have full control of our machines today
your computer's already make the
majority of buy and sell decisions in
our financial markets assemble products
evaluate the work product of human
workers render medical judgments and
diagnosis guide airplanes and conduct a
myriad of other tasks on which we depend
and by which we are deeply affected and
that's with machines that are still a
million times simpler today than the
human brain when machines progressed to
be as complex and ultimately more
complex than the human brain which will
happen in the next century our
dependence will only deepen this process
is gradual
and ongoing it's a seamless progression
with no obvious discontinuities our
computers don't yet appear to be
conscious players in this drama
no one wondered what deep blue thought
of its own victory or Garry Kasparov's
press conference it's brilliant to
playing chess but it's otherwise an
idiot savant with apparently little
ability to register our opinions or
emotions
no one words today about causing pain
and suffering to their computer programs
but all of this will change not suddenly
but inexorably nonetheless and we can't
address these issues by simply assuming
that the human-machine Nexus represents
strictly in ostium relationship
remember that computers are already
deeply embedded in the grain of our
civilization and this relationship will
ultimately become much more intimate
than it is today we have today
artificial skin bones joints hearts
blood vessels pancreatic implants so why
not replace Italy some of our slow
unreliable in ageing neural circuits
with faster reliable synthetic ones we
already have cochlear implants
why not implants to improve vision
memory and reasoning speed why stop
there these things sound controversial
because there was an article just in
today's things today's New York Times
that human cloning it's considered very
controversial some weeks ago and now
people saying well why not so views of
these things do change the computers of
the 21st century will appear to have
human-like emotions because in at least
some cases their designs will have been
derived from the reverse engineering of
human circuits and like humans they will
have or at least appear to have
spiritual experiences they will wonder
or at least profess to wonder about the
true nature of consciousness and free
will they'll wonder if it's really
possible that humans are capable of
being aware of their own existence or if
we only act as if we are and that's not
adequate to state that such developments
won't occur because of ethical or
political prescriptions the age of very
intelligent machines will not be a
single phenomena
human ethics will face a multiplicity of
slippery slopes now the advent of
machines that match and ultimately
exceed the full range of human intellect
won't arrive on a single day it will be
a seamless ever accelerating progression
and to get a feel for how this will
unfold I'd like to consider some
milestones along the way
now with the impending millennium there
are no shortage of predictions about
what the central next century will be
like and futurism itself has a long
history not a very impressive one one of
the problems with anticipations of the
future is that by the time it's apparent
that these predictions have had little
resemblance to future events it's too
late to get your money back
fortunately you didn't have to pay for
this lecture now let me start with with
a sampling of some of the predictions I
made 10 years ago about the 1990s
because I picked out the better ones but
if you buy the book you can you can see
them all but in 1988 I wrote computer
will defeat the world chess champion
before the year 2000 and will think less
of chess as a result there'll be a
sustained decline in the value of
commodities ie material resources was
most new wealth being created in the
knowledge contents of products and
services leading to sustained economic
growth and prosperity and interestingly
Fed chairman Greenspan did recently
acknowledge that today's unprecedented
sustained prosperity and economic
expansion is due to the creased
efficiency provided by information
technology occasionally you read studies
that say that there's no increased
productivity from information technology
the problem of these studies is they
factor out
the improvement they put it in both the
numerator and the denominator and say we
still only get ten dollars of work done
for $10 we only get an hour of work done
in an hour of course we expect to do a
lot more there's no question that
productivity has increased and my
company's two people can handle the
operations that used to require 15 and
20 people before we had computers to to
organize these things but Greenspan is
really only half right he ignores the
fact that most of the new wealth
created is itself comprised of
information in knowledge a trillion
dollars in Silicon Valley alone
increased efficiency is only part of the
story a worldwide information network
linking almost all organizations in tens
of millions of individuals admittedly
not by the name worldwide web and
warfare almost total reliance and
digital imaging pana recognition and
other software technologies aside with
that smarter machines will win the vast
majority of commercial music will be
created in computer-based synthesizers
with the advent of widespread electronic
communication and the Soviet Union
uncontrollable political forces will be
unleashed these will be methods far more
powerful than the copiers the
authorities have traditionally banned
the authorities will be unable to
control it to tell Italian control of
information will have been broken
continuous speech recognition for
dictation although I did have that in
1993 so we were off by a few years and
then by the year 2000 chips with over a
billion transistors so let me let me
share with you a sampling of some
predictions for particular points in
time in the next century start and these
are predictions I'm developing for the
sequel to the edge of intelligent
machines which is a book where the same
title as a selection start with 2009 the
computer itself the majority of text is
created using continuous speech
recognition but keyboards are still used
also ubiquitous are luiz language user
interfaces using continuous speech and
natural language understanding computer
displays have the have the display
qualities of paper chips are
three-dimensional with many layers of
circuitry supercomputers match at least
the hardware capacity of the human brain
unused computes on the internet are
being harvested creating human brain
capacity virtual parallel supercomputers
there's increasing interest in massively
parallel neural nets genetic algorithms
and other forms of chaotic or complexity
theory computing although the majority
of computes of computers still use
conventional sequential processing
research has been initiated on reverse
engineering the human brain education
the majority of reading is done on
displays although the installed base of
paper documents are still formidable
students of all ages routinely have
their own computer which is a very thin
slab weighing about a pound with a very
high-resolution display suitable for
reading intelligent courseware has
emerged as a primary means of learning
learning is becoming a significant
portion of most jobs learning at a
distance is commonplace translating
telephone technology is commonly used
from any language parents telephone
communication is primarily wireless and
routinely includes high resolution
moving images meetings of all kinds and
sizes routinely take place with
geographically separated participants
haptic technologies allow you to touch
and feel objects and people at a
distance people have sexual experiences
at a distance with other persons as well
as virtual partners Business and
Economics despite occasional Corrections
the ten years leading up to 2009 has
seen continuous economic expansion and
prosperity at least half of all
transactions are conducted online
intelligent assistance which combined
continuous speech recognition natural
language understanding problem-solving
and animated personalities routinely
assist with finding information
answering questions and conducting
transactions a company west of the
Mississippi and north of the mason-dixon
line achieves a trillion dollars in
market capitalization I take no
responsibility for that if you make
investment decisions political and
social issues privacy has emerged as a
primary political issue the virtual
constant years of electronic
communication technologies leaves a
highly detailed trail of every person's
move there's a growing neo-luddite
movement as the skill ladder ie the
ladder a level of skill needed for
meaningful employment continues to move
upwards as with earlier Luddite
movements its influence is limited by
the level of prosperity made possible by
new technology the movement does succeed
in establishing continuing education as
a primary right associated with
employment musicians routinely jam with
cybernetic musicians philosophy there's
a renewed interest in the Turing test
which I won't describe but many of you
familiar with it although computers
still fail the test there's greater
confidence that they will be in a
position to pass a test within another
one or two decades this is a test for
seeing if computers have human
equivalents in in intelligence at least
one proposed by Alan Turing there's
increasingly serious speculation on the
in potential sentience or consciousness
of computer-based intelligence the
increasing intelligence of computers has
spurred an interest in philosophy and
now will jump to 2019 about twenty years
from now the computer itself computers
are now largely invisible they are
embedded everywhere in tables chairs
desks clothing jewelry vehicles people
who routinely use three-dimensional
displays built in their glasses computer
displays create highly realistic virtual
visual environments overlaying the real
environment this display technology
projects images directly onto the human
retina
there's widely use regardless of visual
impairment keyboards are rare although
they still exist most interaction with
computing is through physical gesture
which computers respond to both visually
and physically and through spoken
communication computers are facile with
two-way natural language communication
people communicate with computers the
same way they would communicate with a
human assistant significant attention is
paid to the personality of
computer-based personal assistants with
many choices available typically people
don't just own one specific personal
computer
although computing is nonetheless very
personal the computational capacity of
$1,000.00 computing device exceeds the
computational competin capability of the
human brain of the total combined
computing capacity of the human species
ie all human brains together with the
computing technology that the species
has created more than 10 percent is non
human the majority of computes of
computers are now devoted to massively
parallel neural nets and genetic
algorithms significant progress has been
made in the scanning based reverse
engineering of the human brain it's now
fully recognised that the brain is
comprised of many specialized regions
with the topology and architecture of
the internal connections varying widely
depending on the region's information
processing function the massively
parallel algorithms are beginning to be
understood it's recognized that the
human genetic code does not specify the
sites in a neuronal wiring of any of
these regions but rather sets up a rapid
evolutionary process
in which connections are established and
fight for survival the standard process
for wiring machine based neural nets
uses a similar genetic evolutionary
algorithm education most learning is
accomplished using intelligent virtual
teachers to the extent the teaching is
done by human teachers the human
teachers are often not in the local
vicinity of the student the majority of
adult human work could spend the
majority of their time learning new
skills and knowledge communication you
can do virtually anything with anyone
regardless of physical proximity the
technology to accomplish this is easy to
use and ever-present routinely available
technology includes high quality speech
the speech language translation for most
common language pairs Business and
Economics rapid economic expansion and
prosperity has continued the vast
majority of transactions include a
simulated person which includes a
realistic animated personality and
two-way voice communication with high
quality natural language understanding
political and social issues people are
beginning to have relationships with
automated personalities and use them as
companions teachers caretakers and
lovers automated personalities of
superior to humans in some ways such as
having very reliable memories and
predictable personalities they are not
yet regarded as equal to human in the
subtlety of their personalities although
there is disagreement on this point
and undercurrent of concern is
developing with regard to the influence
of machine intelligence that continues
to be differences between human and
machine intelligence but the advantages
of human intelligence are becoming more
difficult to identify and articulate
computer intelligence is thoroughly
inter woven into the mechanisms of
civilization and is designed to be
outwardly subservient to our apparent
human control on the one hand human
transactions and decisions require by
law a human agent of responsibility even
if fully initiated by machine
intelligence on the other hand few
decisions are made without significant
involvement in consultation with machine
based intelligence virtual artists in
all of the arts are emerging and are
taken seriously these virtual artists
musicians and authors tend to be
associated with humans or organizations
which intend are in turn are comprised
of collaborations of humans and machines
who have contributed to the knowledge
base and techniques of these cybernetic
artists however interest in the output
of these creative machines has gone
beyond the mere novelty of machines
being creative visual musical and
literary art created by human artists is
typically a collaboration between human
and machine intelligence the type of
artistic and entertainment object and
greatest demand continues to be virtual
experience software philosophy there are
widespread reports of computers passing
the Turing tests although these tests do
not meet the criteria established by
knowledgeable observers there's
increasingly serious discussion of the
subjective experience of computer-based
intelligence although discussion of the
rights of machine intelligence is not
yet a mainstream debate machine
intelligence is still largely the
product of a collaboration of human and
machine intelligence and has been
programmed to maintain a subservient
relationship to the species that created
it can we jump to 2029 computer itself
$1000 unit of computation has a
computing capacity of approximately
10,000 human brains of the total
combined computing capacity of the human
species along with the competing
technology that it initiated the
creation of more than 99% is non-human
the vast majority of computes of
non-human computing is now massively
parallel knurled and that's much of
which is based on the reverse
engineering of the
Grainne many but less than a majority of
the specialized regions of the human
brain have been decoded with their
massively parallel algorithms understood
the number of specialized regions
numbering in the hundreds is greater
than was anticipated 20 years earlier
displays are now implanted in the eyes
for the choice of permanent implants or
removable implants similar to contact
lenses images are projected directly
onto the retina providing the usual
high-resolution three-dimensional
display overlaid on the physical world
cochlear implants originally used just
for the hearing impaired and now
ubiquitously used these implants provide
both auditory input an output between
the human user and the worldwide
computing network direct neural pathways
have been perfected for direct high
bandwidth connection to the human brain
a range of neural implants are becoming
available to enhance visual and auditory
perception and interpretation memory and
reasoning human learning is primarily
accomplished using virtual teachers and
enhanced by the widely available neural
implants automated agents are learning
on their own without human spoon-feeding
of information and knowledge computers
have read all available human and
machine generated literature significant
new knowledge is created by machines
with little or no human intervention
human and non-human intelligences are
primarily focused on the creation of
knowledge in its myriad forms and their
significant struggle over intellectual
property rights including
ever-increasing levels of litigation
there's almost no human employment in
production agriculture and
transportation the largest profession is
education there are many more lawyers
and doctors computers appear to be
passing forms of the Turing test deemed
valid by both human and non-human
authorities although controversy on this
point persists there's not a sharp
division between the human world and the
machine world human cognition is being
ported to machines and many machines
have personalities skills and knowledge
bases derived from the reverse
engineering of human intelligence
conversely machine intelligence based
neural implants are providing enhanced
perceptual and cognitive functions to
humans there's growing discussion of
what constitutes a human being
this is emerging as a significant legal
and political issue the rapidly growing
capability of machines is can't
Hershel but there's no effective
resistance to it since machine
intelligence was initially designed to
be subservient to you in control it has
not presented a threatening face to the
human population humans realize that
disengaging the now human machine
civilization from its dependence on
machine intelligence is not possible
there's growing discussion of the legal
rights of machines particularly machines
that are independent of humans although
not yet fully recognized in law the
pervasive influence of machines in all
levels of decision-making is providing
significant protection to machines
although computers routinely pass valid
forms of the Turing test that continues
to be controversy as to whether or not
machine intelligence is equal of human
intelligence in all of its diversity the
subjective experience of machine
intelligence is increasingly accepted
particularly since machines participate
in this discussion machine machines
claim to be conscious and these claims
are largely accepted they claim to have
his wide range of emotional and
spiritual experiences as a human
progenitors okay we'll jump finally to
year 2099 this a strong trend towards a
merger of human cognition and perception
with the world of machine intelligence
which the human species initiated the
creation of the reverse engineering of
the human brain appears to be complete
the hundreds of specialized regions have
been fully scanned
analyzed and understood machine
analogues are based on these human
models which have been enhanced and
extended along with many other massively
parallel algorithms these enhancements
combined with the enormous advantages
and speed and capacity of electronic
photonic circuits provide substantial
advantages to machine based intelligence
there's ubiquitous use of neural implant
technology which provides enormous
augmentation of human perceptual and
cognitive abilities humans who do not
utilize such implants have difficulty
engaging in meaningful dialogues with
those who do there are machine based
intelligences entirely derived from
models of human intelligence although
substantially enhanced in terms of speed
and processing memory capacity and
perceptual and cognitive ability these
intelligence is claimed to be human
although the brains are not based on
carbon-based cellular processes and
there are many gradations above these
two scenarios the concept of what it is
to be human has been significantly
altered the rights and powers of
different manifestations of human and
machine intelligences and their various
combinations represent a primary
political and philosophical issue well
let me let me end this lecture with just
a couple of philosophical mind
experiments and these are experiments
that philosophers have thought about
actually long before we had the
computational technology to even
conceivably implement these mind
experiments well consider the statement
I am lonely and bored please keep me
company now if your computer displayed
that on its screen would that convince
you that your notebook is conscious and
has feelings well clearly no and it's
rather trivial for a program to display
such a message and presumably the
message comes from the human author of
the program the computer is just a
conduit for the message much like a book
or a fortune cookie suppose we add
speech synthesis and the computer now
speaks its plaintive message have you
changed anything
well we've added some technical
complexity to the program and some
human-like communication means but we
still don't regard the computer as the
genuine author of the message suppose
now that the message is not explicitly
programmed but it's produced by a game
playing program that contains a complex
model of its own situation the specific
message may never have been foreseen by
the human authors of the program it's
created by the computer from the state
of its own internal model as it
interacts with you the user are we
getting closer to considering the
computer as a conscious feeling entity
well maybe just a tad but if we consider
contemporary game software this illusion
is probably short-lived as we run up
against the
the limitations behind the computer's
ability to small talk now suppose the
mechanisms behind the message grow to
become a massive neural net built from
silicon but based on a reverse
engineering of the human brain
suppose we develop a learning protocol
for the neural net that enables it to
learn human language and model human
knowledge it circuits our million times
faster than human circuits so it has
plenty of time to read all human
literature and develop its own
conceptions of reality its creators
don't tell it how to respond to the
world suppose now that it says I'm
lonely at what point do we consider the
computer to be a conscious agent with
its own free will and what exactly do
these words mean anyway this has been
really the most vexing problem in
philosophy since the Platonic dialogues
illuminated the haird contradiction we
have in these terms let's consider this
slippery slope from the opposite
direction our friend Jack circa sometime
in the 21st century has been complaining
lately of some difficulty with this
hearing a diagnostic test indicates he
needs more than a conventional hearing
aid so he gets a cochlear implant once
used only by people with severe hearing
impairments these implants are now
common to correct the ability of people
to hear across the entire sonic spectrum
the surgical procedure is successful and
Jack is pleased with this improved
hearing is this still the same person
well sure he is people have cochlear
implants today in 1997 we still regard
them as the same person now jack is so
impressed with the success of his
cochlear implants that he likes to
switch on the built-in phonic cognition
circuits and these circuits already
built-in so in case he decides to use
them he doesn't need another insertion
procedure so by activating these neural
replacement circuits the phonics
detection Nets built into the implant
bypass his own aging neural phonics
regions as cash account is also debited
for use of this additional neural
software
and again jackets pleased with his
improved ability to understand what
people are saying did we still have the
same jack of course no one gives it a
second thought
jack is now sold on the ax benefits of
this merging neural implant technology
his retinas are working okay so he keeps
them intact but he decides to try out
the newly introduced image processing
implants and it's amazed at how more
vivid and rapid his visual perception
has become same Jack why sure
Jack notices that his memory is not what
it was as he struggles to recall names
and the details of earlier events and so
on so he's back for memory implants now
these are amazing memories that had
grown fuzzy over the years and now
crystal clear some he would have
preferred to remain fuzzy
still the same Jack well clearly he's
changed in some ways and his friends are
impressed with his improved faculties
but he still has the same
self-deprecating humor the same silly
grin yep it's still the same guy so why
stop here ultimately jack will have the
option of scanning his entire brain a
neural system which is not entirely
located in the skull and replacing it
with electronic photonic circuits of far
greater capacity speed and reliability
there's also the benefit of keeping a
backup copy in case anything happens to
the physical Jack now certainly the
specter is unnerving
maybe amusing maybe more frightening
than appealing and undoubtedly it will
be controversial for a long time but
just keep in mind how long human cloning
was controversial and according to the
exponentially growing pace of
technological change a long time will
not be as long as it used to be but
ultimately the overwhelming benefits of
replacing unreliable neural circuits
with improved ones will be too
compelling to ignore at some point and
if not in the 21st century then most
likely in the next there will be Jack's
who go all the way have we lost jack
somewhere along the line Jack's friends
think not
also claims he's the same old guy just
newer his hearing vision memory
reasoning ability perceptual ability
will improved but it's still the same
jack
now we could we could extend this
scenario in mind experiment in many
different ways but I'd like to leave
some time for discussion so let me just
touch on one other issue which which is
to put aside the continuity of
consciousness and just consider the
fundamental issue of the existence of
consciousness itself how do we know that
it exists at all I really only have one
data point which is my own consciousness
I am conscious I have experiences I have
emotions I can infer that I exist this
is de cartes famous dictum and although
it's been interpreted as a symbol of
Western rational philosophy which
describes fundamental reality to the
physical world
the carts simple statement is just this
I think if I II I have conscious
experiences therefore I am therefore I
exist but I also know that I'm not the
only conscious entity in the world or do
I actually I have no evidence for this
but I assume it to be the case as
otherwise would be difficult to maintain
my sanity and I'd say this in the first
person because that is where I have to
start but what evidence do I have that
other people are also conscious well
maybe after an hour of this lecture I am
the only conscious person in this room
but I maintain that the evidence is not
scientific evidence at all because it's
not a scientific question we can of
course correlate certain expressions of
conscious experience with certain
patterns of observed neural functioning
and there is research along this lines
but that does not constitute scientific
proof for the subjective experience of
another entity even if that entity is a
person from the thought experiment at
the beginning of this discussion ie the
computer says I'm lonely we know that an
entity claiming to be having a
particular experience is not proof that
it is so not only about the entity be
having a different experience and it's
claiming to have it might not be
conscious at all now I assume and I
assume we all assume
that other people have conscious
experiences somewhat similar to mine
because they're convincingly displaying
behaviors that are similar to my own
behaviors when having certain
experiences in other words if I see
somebody crying I assume they're having
experience similar to ones I've had when
I felt sad and displayed a similar
behavior but despite my empathetic
reaction there's no direct way to
measure the subjective experience of
another person now although we humans
all tend to assume that each other is
conscious as we move away from shared
human experience human views of this
issue begin to diverge quite radically
for example the issue of animal
consciousness are animals conscious
creatures making decisions and
experiencing feelings to many humans
including this speaker it seems apparent
that this is the case again based on
this empathetic perception of animals
displaying behavior similar to my own
but opinion on this is far from
unanimous and if we disagree on the
subjective experience of animals then we
might conclude that there's far greater
opportunity for disagreement when it
comes to the subjective experience of
machines so far it doesn't seem like
much of a debate with our machines still
a million times simpler than the human
brain their complexity and subtlety is
comparable to that of insects but as
we've talked about this philosophical
debate will become far less abstract as
the next century unfolds we will have
jacks who have indeed replaced and
supplemented some and eventually someday
all of their neural circuitry with
electronic photonic equivalents
conversely will have computers that have
been derived in part or in whole from
scans and reverse engineering of humans
and there will be many variations in
combinations of these scenarios so who
and what is conscious when is the
professed feelings of an entity to be
taken at face value and when is it to be
regarded as a programmed response when
is destruction of an entity to be
considered destruction of property and
when is it murder when do we have to be
concerned about causing pain and
suffering to our computer programs in
the 21st century this this polite debate
of the last two millenniums will become
the primary political strong
and how will this issue be resolved in
my view the outcome will favor the
machines first recall that many of us
are convinced that animals have their
own subjective life as a result of our
noticing behaviors and animals that are
similar to those in humans this
phenomena will actually be stronger with
regard to machines of the 21st century
because these machines will be based in
large part on human designs they will
appear very familiar to us and as the
above scenarios point out they will
indeed claim to be human to be your old
friend to be jack
even if instantiated in electronic
photonic substrate second the machines
will be part of the debate they will be
sufficiently persuasive to profoundly
influence the discussion thank you
Thank You race so much for this
provocative and a fascinating do to the
future so I guess they are some
questions comments flames from the
United States were very gone through
there we had forty percent of our
population working out culture in
nineteen hundred today it's three
percent so well I mean we've survived
that transition
we're undergoing a similar transition
now in production labor in factories but
within a few years the percentage of
population actually working assembling
products and factories will be under
five percent where the I mean this is
the the the challenge of the Luddites in
in the late 18th century when these
textile machines started coming out and
people one person could do the work of
10 with with a machine it was just
obvious that employment was on its way
out it would just be had buying a lead
well we've actually seen if you look at
say the last hundred years when most of
human automation has taken place as
we've gone from in the United States
twelve million jobs in 1870 to 130
million jobs today from employing some
like twenty five percent of the
population to almost sixty percent of
the population and the jobs are at a
much higher level and a lot of the new
employment is in fact in education to
provide a higher level of education
required and that's that's the skill
ladder that I referred to we're adding
jobs at the top of the skill ladder and
removing
them at the bottom and a lot of the new
employment is in education to provide
those skills and so far the human race
has been able to keep up with that and
jobs today are more interesting they pay
eight times as much in constant dollars
today compared to 1870 so so far it's
been a very good thing because the
challenge is what happens I mean can we
keep pace with that indefinitely as a
skill ladder moves up I don't know
[Applause]
even entity will be obsolete to some
degree like if you have entities that
are completely independent from the
substrate already you have multiple
backups the issues like physical
immortality they just go but what
happened with like as we were saying you
can modify your identity very rapidly
once in a while you will experience what
I would call death forward its
modification beyond the recognition so
the physical substrate lifespan issue
would be replaced with the identity like
Spanish also if you have complete memory
of your experiences you can do funny
things like personality rewind and if
you have a distributed fluid
architecture that is global what you can
do you can employ multiple sensors
actuators processes for a cognitive task
on a contractual basis that then
dissolve the whole thing so it's hard to
say what exactly is an entity wants what
well the question has to do with what
what constitutes the identity of a
person used the word entity but I think
that's what you were getting at and it's
the issue that I've started to get into
the end of my remarks that's it's an
issue we could talk a long time about I
mean there two schools of thought one is
that we are these particles and that's
what I am and the other school of
thought is I'm not the particles at all
I'm the pattern it's like a it's like
the shape that you see in a in a stream
if you see water rushing around a rock
you see a certain shape and that shape
could remain constant for hours but in
fact the particles are changing every
few milliseconds is the water rushes
through now there's a stronger argument
for the pattern than there is for the
particles because in fact we are like
the Eddy in a brook because our
particles are constantly changing we
change most of our cells every few years
not nerve cells but he
nerve cells we changed the particles
that comprise the cells every few years
I mean every two or three years were
completely different set of particles
but it's in at least a continuum of the
same pattern so that would argue for the
pattern but you could make a strong
counter example for that and if you
scanned somebody you now have that
information and then you instantiated
that person in a new substrate and the
person walks out and thinks it's the
same person but the old person is still
there and that old person thinks he's
the same person and in fact may not even
be aware that you've a copy of him that
would tend to contradict the pattern
argument is a real issue my question was
actually posed a hundred years ago by
Swami Vivekananda and I'd like to pose
it better and what he said was this
there is a great discussion going on as
to whether the aggregate of materials
because the body is the cause of the
manifestation of the force we call the
soul thought and so on whether it is
thought that manifests this body the
religions of the world of course hold
that that the force called thought
manifests the body and not the reverse
there are schools of modern thought
which hold that that which we call
thought is simply the outcome of the
adjustment of the parts of the machine
which we call the body taking the second
position that the soul or the mass of
thoughts or whatever we may call it is
the outcome of this machine the outcome
of the character
physical combinations of matter making
up the body and brain leaves a question
unanswered what makes the body what
force combines the molecules into a body
form what force is there which takes up
material from the mass of matter around
it and forms my body one way another
body another way and so on what makes
these infinite distinctions to say that
the force called the soul is the outcome
of the combination of the molecules of
the body is putting the cart before the
horse
how did the combinations come what force
was there to make them if you see that
some other force was the cause of these
combinations and the soul which is now
seen to be combined with a particular
mass of matter is itself the result of
the combinations of these material
particles which is no answer that theory
ought to be taken which explains most if
not all of the facts without
contradicting other existing theories it
is more logical to say that the force
which takes up the matter and forms a
body is the same which is manifested
through that body so let me repeat the
question well I think it's a good
example of how this issue has been
considered long before computers were
evident there really again two schools
of thought the Western school of thought
is that the fundamental reality is stuff
matter particles and that they swirl
around and evolve and eventually evolved
intelligent entities that are conscious
the view that's been say associated with
Eastern thought is that what's
fundamentally the fundamental reality is
consciousness not not matter of
particles and thought which is a
manifestation of consciousness and that
matter is what we have to be conscious
of and essentially we start with
consciousness and create matter is a
projection of consciousness it's
interesting that in the 20th century
Western science has come around to
ascribing a real fundamental reality to
consciousness because in quantum
mechanics particles do not decide where
they're going
or even where they have gone until they
are forced to do so by a conscious
observer and there's a fundamental
reality to consciousness and so we do
see a blending of these two schools
system is certainly tied in strongly to
our neural system the chemical
messengers are very strongly influenced
by the endocrine system and that's the
whole genesis of my mood altering drugs
such as Prozac and so on but those
processes are not actually nearly as
complex as the neural process itself and
there's no reason why they can't be
emulated as well to the extent that we
want to emulate them or need to emulate
them as for consciousness being not a
local process we don't really know what
consciousness is I really don't think
it's a scientifically observable process
but it is true that the human cognitive
processes are not localized they are
more like holographic processes our
memories are based on the patterns of
connections in a region and that is that
that's the essence of neural net
processing I mean that's not inherent to
human beings it is quite different than
the way most computers work today which
is sequential and logically organized
our sequential rational functions which
are in the cortex which is the folded up
two-dimensional surface which is a
fairly late evolutionary development
it's a very small part of our neural
processing most of the human processing
is pattern recognition
which is highly distributed but we can
emulate that in machines as well and a
lot of the anti AI backlash is really
focused on just symbolic processing
which is one technique it's just a valid
technique but we won't get to emulate
many types of intelligence particularly
the whole area of pattern recognition by
just using sequential processing in that
I had an interesting discussion with
Marie Campbell of the IBM deep blue team
that is cost the deep blue is is a
ultimate example of sequential
processing taken to an extreme and the
computer builds up this massive tree of
moving counter moves and at the end it
finally has to evaluate a leaf position
and it does that with a grab bag of
rules that they've just hand tuned which
is fairly much a hodgepodge of rules I
said why don't you replace that with a
neural net and you can train the neural
net on every master game that's been
played in the century which they have on
their hard drive and he thought that was
an interesting idea and started to work
on that but then they cancelled the
project but it is possible actually to
use both types of techniques
she's presumably if we did that lacking
a perfect human to do it
we'd also implement ethology of thought
in machines have you considered the
implications for machine pathologies
for example socio pathologies that might
in fact lend them less of the benevolent
picture which the benevolence that this
is what you have affected there many
different scenarios we wouldn't
necessarily want to copy one person
unless in fact that's what we're
intending to do is to capture a
particular personality but the the
primary scenario is articulating was
it's not just to scan the information in
a dumb way which it's basically what
we've done today with the genetic code
we have the entire human genetic code
actually we'll have in about twelve
months but we don't understand it it's
kind of a machine code and we're trying
to we're trying to do a disassembly of
and understand the source code we don't
know what the source language is but
what we really would like to do with the
genetic code is understand it and what
we would like to do with the
interneuronal connections it's really
understand the algorithms now the one
example I gave of Carver Meads work
they've done exactly that they looked at
the connections and they were actually
able to figure out what the algorithm is
and then implement that in silicon so
it's very clever work and that's really
the primary thrust of my argument which
is we will find that there are hundreds
of different specialized regions the
brain is not one tabula rasa just one
big neural net that organizes itself
they're very highly specialized regions
that deal with vision or hearing or or
music memory of different kinds
emotional regions and each of these have
different structures that are highly
specialized for their tasks and we
certainly will will be a great benefit
to understanding human behavior to
actually begin to understand how the
brain works and I believe that will be
feasible and you don't necessarily have
to see every single connection because
in these early vision circuits it's very
highly repetitive so after you've seen
50 of them
you don't have to see all 50 million
circuits
s'okay will gain a lot of insight into
human behavior and will also learn some
intelligent algorithms that we can then
apply to to to computer problems we have
one last flame
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm repeating the question further
well the question dealt with whether or
not machines would remain subservient
and whether or not we'll want to give
them human rights and then point it out
that there won't really be necessary
since they won't really care about that
I think I mean computers will provide a
benevolent and subservient face but that
could be as much a tactic as a strategy
or a reality it is the case generally
that the more intelligent organism or
species or civilization or the
civilization with the superior
technology has generally been dominant
for better or for worse so whatever
intelligence is a is a form of power
knowledge is power and machines will
have that what will have the power
consistent with their capability but
again it's not an us them Nexus I think
human beings we will enhance our
abilities through this type of
technology and we will be part of of
that of that future it's it's a combined
it's a combined civilization really
which ultimately will merge human and
machine capabilities thank you very much
[Applause]